trate secrecy is high on the agenda this
month as European Union ministers
responsible for ensuring competitiveness
meet in Brussels The ministers will try
to agree a common approach to new rules
to better protect trade secrets which
are vital to businesses and underpinned
fair competition the aims to make it
easier for national courts to deal with
the problem and for victims to be
compensated as well as remove products
that infringe on trade secrets from the
market a council agreement would pave
the way for negotiations to begin with
the European Parliament The ministers
will also seek agreement on a
requirement for new cars to be fitted
with an emergency call system for use in
accidents throughout Europe known as
equal the council agreed in early May to
deploy the eu-wide system which would
consist of a wireless device that
manufacturers fit to cars and which
would trigger a call to the 112
emergency number it's hoped that equal
can speed up the emergency response to
road accidents and bring down casualty
numbers as the Union looks to half
traffic deaths by the year twenty twenty